dans cette centrifugeuse ils sont dans
la peau d'un pilote de chasse sous cette
pression gravitationnelle n'importe qui
perdrait connaissance mais dans cette
combinaison du futur c'est homme
inexpérimenté supporter jusqu'à 11 g
soit 11 fois leur poids en comprimant
l'ensemble du corps le tissu empêche
l'apparition du voile noir une
innovation majeure
jusqu'à présent les combinaisons
n'agissait que sur la partie inférieure
du corps
nous avons une combinaison de vol qui
comprime y compris les bras légèrement
le rôle du torse et l'intégralité de la
partie base du corps pour permettre en
fait une amélioration de la protection
anti g à peu près cinq fois supérieur à
ce que ce pantalon pour offrir cet
équipement fruit de dix années de
recherche sera bientôt sur le marché
pour le fabriquer cet entrepreneur
suisse a choisi la franche-comté 250
emplois seront créés à vesoul pour
assembler les combinaisons passer la
frontière
un choix stratégique avec l'étiquette
made in france le groupe espère
atteindre un client très convoité
l'armée de l'air française
si nous amenons à savoir faire dans une
technologie nouvelle qui elle jusqu'à
présent n'a que peu évolué et je pense
que c'est un atout décisif aussi pour un
pays
nous espérons définitivement touché une
corde sensible aussi de ce côté là bien
sûr comme cette société depuis plus d'un
siècle la suisse implante des usines
chez sa voisine comtoise dans les années
à venir la tendance devrait se confirmer
pour les helvètes
la franche comté est la plus proche
porte d'entrée vers le marché européen
accéder au marché français puis aux
marchés de l'union européenne ce a
neutralisé le taux de change les passage
en douane et taxes diverses et variées
toutes ces tracasseries finalement
inutile et
à nous de bien accueillir les projets
suisses sur les différents territoires
en fonction des circonstances
grâce à une entreprise suisse lahoud
somme pourrait donc renouer avec son
passé industriel textile
les premiers recrutements sont en cours